- Ow! Can I kiss it again?
- I have a bag of mystery items
I'm going to have you close your eyes.
- Okay.
- Close your eyes.
- You're going to kiss, you're already in?
- Yeah!
- Kiss a foreign object,
see if you can guess it.
Are you down?
- Absolutely.
- Keep it weird.
- Always down for a challenge.
- God, I'm not going
to be very good at it.
- Yeah, that's the point.
- Okay, Shawn, close your eyes please.
How many fingers?
- Good, don't cheat.
- Three.
- Don't cheat, okay, I'm trusting you.
- Okay, got it.
- So, I guess just pucker up or whatever.
(kissing noises)
- It has hair on it.
- What is that, that's slimy? (laughs)
- Man, I really--
- It's a normal thing.
- It's a normal thing?
It's in every household with a child.
You want to try again?
- No.
- Ah! I opened my eyes.
I couldn't take it.
- It's like a Barbie doll?
- Wow, really good Kathy.
Have you kissed a Barbie doll before?
- Yeah, many.
- I have to kiss it?
- Yeah.
- Ow!
- Oh, baby.
- Oh, okay.
- That's a microphone.
You kissed the microphone.
- Is it a candle?
- A hairbrush.
- That just got so much weirder.
- Can I kiss it again?
- Please, as many times as you like.
Here you go, Chloe.
What are you?
You're like open mouthing it.
- I know exactly what that is.
I've kissed that many times.
- Is that a pine cone?
- It's a pine cone!
- That is a pine-freaking-cone.
- Apple cinnamon pine cone.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, I got it right!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
(kissing noises)
- Pencil?
- Again.
- That is so weird!
- It's kind of roundish.
- Like all pencils.
A nice sound effect with each one.
- I was looking, I was looking.
- Shawn, what are you doing?
- I'm sorry.
- Also a little adorable lipstick mark.
- I was like, what is he--
- Shawn, Shawn, close your eyes.
- I'm sorry, I opened my eyes.
But I knew it was a toy.
I knew it was a toy
- This game involves trust.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- (mumbles) trust.
- I'm sorry.
- Oh, it's a duck.
- It's a rubber duck.
- Yes.
- Oh my God, come on.
Are you serious?
That, by the way--
- Adorable.
- Was a very awkward thing to kiss.
- I've never kissed a rubber
duck, you're the weird one.
- This is what I kissed?
See, you put the hair on my lips.
I got so confused.
- It was an accident.
- No it wasn't at all.
- You want to keep one of these?
- Yeah, I want to keep the rubber duck.
Thanks, does it squeak?
- I don't think so.
- Oh.